hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
today we're going to take a look at
America's greatest showman PT Barnum
PT Barnum was an American showman
businessman and entertainer above all
else he was a salesman and promoter who
knew how to get people talking today the
legacy of his work lives on in Ringling
Brothers and Barnum and Bailey Circus
still billed as the greatest show on
earth
when PT Barnum first launched his
business there was heavy competition as
many entrepreneurs had set up their own
traveling road shows he knew that in
order for his circuses succeed he needed
to get people excited about it by being
extremely different from everyone else
even if you didn't have a ticket to a
show when Barnum circus was in town you
would know it he would sweep through
into the city with gusto elephants would
be paraded through the streets and
clowns would be sent to local hospitals
to visit with sick children Barnum was
providing a pre-show to his circus that
got people talking and raised the
excitement levels about his acts he
would offer tours of his circus anyone
who wanted to see inside the big top and
also put on a myriad of free contests in
order to attract crowds to the circus
Barnum schemes always worked people
would show up in droves as with the
media he was always thinking of ways to
promote both himself and his circus from
making splashy entrances to using
cross-promotion Barnum did what it took
to make sure people knew who he was so
the next question becomes how can you
model the success of PT Barnum here are
three action tips you can put to use in
your business today action item number
one sell something unique how do you
really stack up against your competitors
are you honestly that different if
you're an average company with an
average product selling at an average
price then guess what you get average
results to be successful you have to
have a point of differentiation it has
to be something that is noticeable to
people who don't understand your
industry in the circus business you have
to get good performers and PT Barnum
went out of his way to find the best
from the Fiji mermaid to the Siamese
twins Chang and Eng bunker the General
Tom Thumb the [ __ ] PT Barnum had a
unique product that none of his
competitors could match think about if a
potential customer found your website
and five of your competitors websites
would they get the feeling that you're
very different from the others be honest
with yourself
and if the answer is not really then
it's time to get to work on creating an
offering that is truly unique in your
industry action item number two
promote promote promote you can have the
greatest product or service in the world
but if nobody knows about it your
business won't last very long whatever
market you're selling to is likely full
of competitors even if you have a better
quality product or service your
competition can get more business than
you if they promote themselves properly
to be a successful entrepreneur you need
to both provide an outstanding offering
see action item number one and promote
it so everybody knows about it one of my
favorite quotes from PT Barnum is
without promotion something terrible
happens nothing if you're not out
promoting and selling your product and
your competitors are taking your
customers from you even if you can
provide them with a better option if
you're not out promoting then you lose
and your customers lose promoting your
business doesn't have to be expensive
and you don't have to be a great people
person you just have to do something
unique to stand out according to the New
York Times the average person in a city
sees 5000 ads per day unless you're very
very unique and different with your
promotion people are going to ignore you
they're not trying to be mean we're all
just train the filter things out unless
we have a reason to pay attention give
them that reason to pay attention and
with your next promotion ask yourself
what would PT Barnum do
action item number three showcase
yourself people like to buy from people
not from companies think about your own
buying experiences would you rather buy
from someone who you can see their
picture learn about their story and
relate to their experiences or would you
rather buy from ABC company who uses the
same stock photography and Boeing
mission statements as everyone else PT
Barnum did a great job of not only
promoting his business but himself as a
part of it he was a creative founder who
everyone was talking about and wanted to
learn more about you don't have to be a
daredevil like Richard Branson and
balloon around the world although PT
Barnum would be proud but it can really
help your business if you showcase
yourself so that your prospective
customers feel like they're buying from
a real human being put your picture on
your website and in your marketing
materials tell a brief story as to why
you started your business and the
problems you've been able to help solve
for your customers explain why you're so
proud of your business and what makes
you different it will have a tremendous
and long-lasting impact on your
company's growth so remember sell
something unique promote promote promote
and showcase yourself now I want to end
the video with one of my favorite true
stories about PT Barnum one of the
houses PT Barnum owned was located in
Connecticut it was a large estate
situated near set of high-traffic
railroad tracks what made the land so
unique was that Barnum would frequently
use an elephant to plow his yard he took
every chance he could to promote his
circus each time a train passed by his
house on to wait in New York City
hundreds of passengers would see Barnum
and the elephant it was a living
advertisement that spoke volumes and
intrigue to commuters as a zip by who
was this man and why was he on an
elephant in his backyard they all wanted
to know newspapers reporters came from
far and near and wrote glowing account
of the elephantine performances said
Barnum the six acres were plowed over at
least 60 times before I thought the
advertisements efficiently circulated
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the Masters
to hear your thoughts if you want to
leave a comment below and stay tuned for
the next edition